now I heard that you were meeting to get
in touch with me but then I heard you
were dead and I also heard that you were
a king and various other things but the
fact is Loki you and I are not the sword
people understand sort people fear now I
got the information that I needed now I
have to break your neck it's just the
way it is
I'm not I'm just a messenger
[Music]
I'm dying
you should choose your words more
carefully hey everybody this is kind of
funny Thanos just being the totally
casual bro I'm just the messenger I have
to break your neck but this is no big
deal
so you could probably see why they
deleted this this is from really early
in the stage when they were trying to
perfect the Thanos capture performance
so the cool thing about this though is
that it actually lets us know what
Santos knew about what was going on in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe after the
Battle of New York there's a new round
of that infinity war blu-ray giveaway
going on that I'll talk about at the end
of the video if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna get really crazy
with venom and Captain Marvel really
soon the funny thing about this is that
now we know that he heard about what was
going on with Loki after Thor the dark
world pretending to be Odin so the
reason why he just showed up now I think
I talked about this in a previous video
the Russos actually clarified why Thanos
waited so long to collect all the stones
in the real key to everything was him
getting the location of the soul stone
or at least finding out that Gamora knew
where it was from nebula so that implies
that this post-credit scene from age of
ultron is happening right after she came
back to try and kill him remember it's
not totally linear with this post-credit
scene this is happening right before he
goes to zan dar and that's happening
within the span of a week of infinity
war because this is the events of
infinity war only take place over the
course of a couple days almost less than
that that's how quickly things go down
how quickly he just jumps around the
universe collecting all the stones the
thing about him knowing who Tony Stark
was that's actually from after the
Battle of New York because people
reported that Tony Stark blew up his
ships with that nuke at the end so we
know all the Loki truthers out there are
talking about theories about how he
could come back what's going on here
most of those theories rely on ignoring
what the Russos have said about the Hulk
character as well as ignoring what the
meta commentary of this scene here is
especially when Thanos says no
resurrections this time so the thing
about that the reason why this clip is
so important is because their wiki give
the camera and it's a reference to three
different things one it's a reference to
the last time nanos resurrected Loki
after the first Thor film and taught him
how to use them
in stone and set him on the path to
conquer earth and take the space stone
back during that first Avengers film -
it's a meta joke about all the times the
movies have faked Loki's death they also
did that during thor ragnarok with a
play like we thought that he was at but
nope he'd faked it he's totally alive in
3 it's meant to tell you that Thanos is
really killing him here and he will not
be brought back to life literally no
resurrections as in the filmmakers and
Kevin Feige are saying we're not going
to fake Loki's death this time again the
reason why Loki is showing up in all
these Avengers for behind the scenes
picks from the Battle of New York where
they're all walking around to their
original Avengers costumes is is because
it's the Loki from that period from
before Thor the dark world before
Ragnarok before the events of infinity
war it's not our Loki here that's lying
in this pile here coming back in the
next film this Loki is dead but
originally when he did say the Sun will
shine on us again - Thor I think what he
was referencing was the sun shining on
new Asgard after Thor builds it as Odin
kind of told him to do during Ragnarok
[Music]
from look at this place
it's beautiful
look at that remember this place
[Music]
Oh
this would be a fine place for Asgard
just implying the future of those
Asgardian characters because as Gardea
is the name of new Asgard when Thor
builds it on earth in the comics so I
think he was literally saying the Sun
will shine down and things will be
better you know your eventually
accomplish your goal of helping our
people but also this version of Loki
shining down on him with this devilish
grin from Valhalla thinking of ways to
cause mischief like even though I'm dead
I'm still the god of mischief so it's
not like I'm just gonna sit around in
the afterlife so remember that even
though Tom Hiddleston might be done
being a big character in Marvel movies
Thor speaks with Odin in Valhalla
during Ragnarok after he's died so he
could do the exact same thing with Loki
but no resurrections means no
resurrections so I don't ever expect
this Loki to come back to life but
here's the thing you know multiverse
theories time travel still totally fair
game for future movies though there's
still a lot of questions about what
happened to cord Valkyrie in hella
because we saw hella
seemingly die at the end of Ragnarok
she's such a big character and Cate
Blanchet is such a big actress that I
think that any time that they want to
bring her back and she wants to come
back she will just pop up like oh I was
alive this whole time but within the
context of the story she's the goddess
of death so literate like she's probably
one of the hardest people to kill in the
Marvel Universe
aside from Thanos who just so physically
resilient even without the Infinity
Gauntlet that you need a couple people
to take him down Tessa Thompson who said
that she totally wants to come back
Kevin Feige the producers have said that
she basically escaped that has
guardianship with Korg in about half of
the Asgardian so there's still half of
them that are alive everybody didn't die
on this ship here Thor actually had one
of the biggest arcs during Infinity Ward
it'll be a lot clearer during Avengers 4
when they're all together like those
still be groups during Avengers 4 but
they will spend a good part of the film
together as Avengers like this original
scene here like obviously all these
things calling back to that first
Avengers film the funny thing about core
2 I talked about it in my guardians
video a little while ago because I was
talking about tyka but he actually
already recorded a new dialogue as Korg
so Korg is confirmed alive and daryl is
confirmed alive
good evening everyone and welcome to the
first meeting of the revolution 2.0 or
as I like to call it the re revolution
good news
Darrell survived the snap bad news a lot
of my co-workers didn't so I'm working
Sundays let me know in the comments
though Tom Hiddleston cameos in a future
film not Avengers for what do you want
them to do with the character do you
want him to just give Thor advice from
Valhalla like if Thor has a problem and
whatever next film he pops up in you
know what I'm gonna do just because the
spider-man ps4 game is out next week
I'll do the giveaway for the game
instead of doing the infinity war
blu-ray we'll do that for the rest of
the Marvel videos in the next week or so
congratulations to the winner from my
last big video sock please email me on
the back end of my channel I'll do a new
round when I post new Marvel there's an
Iron Fist trailer that I'm probably
gonna post next so that should be up in
a little while
click here for my new sinister six
spider-man far from home video and click
here to learn about what's going on with
guardians three and four four thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]
you